et nous passons au théâtre maintenant
avec une pièce qui se joue au théâtre
des variétés cela s'appelle les dégourdi
de la 11e en vedette darry cowl mais
aussi robert hirsch et pierre tornade et
jean-claude larigot tout de suite alors
alors ça votre ville qui a été écrit en
1913 puis c'est pas tout je sais pas
tout à fait tout jeune c'est c'est
l'histoire d'un colonel qui commande une
garnison à bar-le-duc dans tout le monde
connaît la poésie canton des bidasses
les colonels reçoit une s une circulaire
du ministère de la défense du 10 ans il
faut organiser les loisirs des soldats
alors ça tombe bien parce qu'il a une
soeur guette une demoiselle prolonger ce
qu'il est veuf bon il ya sa soeur qui
tient son ménage et elle a une manie
cette soeur c'est qu'elle écrit les
tragédies alors faut voir les tragédies
elle aurait dit ça c'est formidable ça
va me régler mes problèmes de famille on
va jouer la tragédie pour les bidasses
alors ça marche très très bien
l'organisme les rôles et puis tout à
coup intervient un général égrillard et
cacochyme joué par darry cowl
ajustements alors lui qui va lancer des
péripéties tout à fait nouvelle dans
cette histoire très très la guerre très
marrante
alors on regarde un extrait cette pièce
au théâtre des variétés tout de suite
donc avec robert et ce darry cowl
nous quoi une sentinelle ne doit-elle
pas s'asseoir ses impôts sous la pluie
mais pas quelqu'un d'autre comme
l'extraction des trois épis nîmes la
routine
une sentinelle je vois ta soir aucun
félin colonna à la romana pour
l'utiliser pour enseigner la théorie
militaire
oh je ne sentirai voilà plus devant
l'océan pologne pas un compte à compte
les propos la part de l'été quart temps
c'est le parcours du combattant
on les rapproche
nous avons la petite simulation aux yeux
de l'ennemi gobain agacement
l'observation des conditions adverses
la serbie avait été affecté au maroc au
service de contre espionnage
alors j ai appris des techniques de
pointe chaque agence et à écouter ça
j'ai pas bien bon faites-moi rapport
communiqué ministériel
qu'est-ce que vous avez confié
et le remet à nos papilles aux tarifs
proposés
si je vous dis que c'est du comics
pompiers qu'est-ce que vous rencontrez
sur la barre ils ont blessé d'une
fantaisie et de fantaisie il se passe
dans une caserne e minute de nos jours
c'est sait plus à quoi ça peut bien
évolué enfin c'est une odeur fed avait
évidemment de caser à dominance après
mais comment comment expliquez vous
cette espèce de retour de la mode des
tours ou parce que vous n'êtes pas tout
seul sur le marché en ce moment à las
vegas le produit ou alors pourquoi
pourquoi pas ce que ça donne quand même
un brin non je sais pas pourquoi mais ça
a commencé donc vous avez pu constater
que face vers il ya beaucoup oui ah bah
oui les gens adorent ça c'est une chose
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
c'est beau c'est plus facile à
comprendre quedes
truc de l'an 2000 de l'an iii dit
inquiet vous pensez je pensais que
j'allais effectué là du tout non non
mais je sais qu'en veille un ambiance là
60 cretey on s'est évidemment et alors
et les dialogues sont des élus du fonds
qui proviennent du fonds de la france
ont fait un cd à l'autre et c'est enfin
1913 les trophées sont pas loin le
pinard et tout ça on croit tout
simplement un peu lourdingue comme on
pourrait dire nous retraités comme ça
non c'est tellement énorme en ont bu je
fais du shopping en scène moi ça va
jusque là on fait je joue le rôle d'un
général déglingué qui à 83 ans alors ça
me change tellement d'ailleurs d'horloge
quand j'ai filmé maquillée de mai tous
les trucs quand je me vois dans la glace
j'ai le sentiment des deux en fait de
faire une autre personne en tout cas
laico le public rit on a entendu
voudrais vous poser une question ce qui
paraît que vous avez failli vous noyer à
quelques jours on a failli y perdre
c'est vrai donc j'assume 18 north bay
pourtant la piscine était calme non mais
c'est oublier jeune âge très bien aider
l'autre jour bêtement comme ça j g je me
suis accroché au bord j'ai raté j'ai
respiré j'ai respiré lincou trois verres
d'eau jupe une tasse énorme suis énervé
je voulais pas respirer mais on y avait
quatre personnes
mais non mais c'était fabuleux parce que
quatre personnes dans la visite et j'ai
alors j'aurais fait un bond attendu
alors j'ai dit il faut absolument faire
des signaux que le moniteur viennent en
que le prêcheur alors j'ai fait des
signaux et le moniteur m'a vu il m'a
fait bon jour finalement une dernière
question d' harry caul tous les grands
acteurs comiques n'ont qu'un rêve c'est
de jouer la tragédie alors ce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est si vous faisait
une proposition bien direct quel
personnage de l'histoire vous aimeriez
camper jeu
paul young par exemple parce que c'est
pas c'est un martyr je vous ai envie de
jouer des rôles de composition même où
jeanne d'arc c'est un gendarme s'amuser
bien comme position oui là je suis
frileux d'habitude
merci darry cowl donc que les dégourdi
de la 11e c'est au théâtre des variétés